bonjour à tous C'est bienvenue et bonne
année à tous je voulais vous souhaiter
une très belle et très heureuse année
2023 une année 2023 pleine de joie et de
bonheur une belle année 2023 très belle
année à la France
les pétards et les feux d'artifice
traditions italienne au soir de la
Saint-Sylvestre mais Naples offre
toujours le spectacle le plus
impressionnant aussi on n'a pas voulu se
priver de vous rejouer cette image d'un
journaliste italien qui tentait
d'expliquer l'an dernier que covid
oblige les feux d'artifice alors étaient
interdits
[Musique]
on y va c'est l'émission
2022 est achevé chacun de vide que 2023
ne sera pas meilleur et pourtant le
chômage baisse et pourtant l'inflation
est moins forte qu'ailleurs et pourtant
les Français sont davantage protégés que
leurs voisins alors pourquoi cette envie
de Prozac sinon à considérer que la
France traverse une crise intellectuelle
culturelle existentielle globalement
l'humanité est optimiste quand on
demande à des humains est-ce que vous
pensez que 2023 va être une meilleure
année 2022 globalement les humains
répondent oui vous voyez vous avez plus
optimistes au monde ce sont les
Brésiliens
alors voilà je me demande si c'est la
2023 avec le nouveau président ou si ils
se disent 2022 on a été éliminé de la
Coupe du monde
[Rires]
le Brésil a officiellement un nouveau
président 12 ans après ces deux premiers
mandats Lula revient il a été investi
hier au palais panalto le siège de la
présidente à Brasilia il a ensuite gagné
le Parlement ou la tendette une marée
humaine vêtue de rouge et il a prononcé
un discours très dur à l'égard de son
prédécesseur jaillir bolsonaro absent de
la cérémonie en rupture de protocoles
c'est sur ces ruines que j'assume
l'engagement de reconstruire le pays il
y a que trois pays sur terre où il y a
plus de pessimistes que de d'optimistes
et vous allez les deviner facilement
d'ailleurs les Français
nous sommes parmi les trois pays les
plus pessimistes au monde il y a que 44%
des Français qui pensent que 2023 sera
mieux 2022 nous sommes à égalité avec il
nous manque visorec les Belges
dépression et des possessions sont les
deux mamelles de ce pays qui ne croient
plus en lui qui ne croit plus en son
unité une France qui ne croit plus en
son destin son avenir en son rayonnement
il y a des réussites individuelles bien
sûr des aventures personnelles il y a
des Français qui vont bien et des
familles unies mais voyez-vous j'ai
l'impression que les Français ne croient
plus en France
[Musique]
adieu 2022 et bienvenue en 2023 pour
célébrer le passage à la nouvelle année
il y avait un million de personnes sur
les Champs-Élysées et autant de
smartphone brandis pour immortaliser
l'événement c'est ce qu'on peut observer
sur cette vidéo très commentée tous avec
leur portable au lieu de profiter mort
de rire j'ai jamais vu une image aussi
terrifiante des résolutions
un peu plus de sport
et arriver à désintoxiquer mes enfants
des tablettes et des portables
bon courage oui bon courage bon courage
si je vais en avoir besoin parmi toutes
les résolutions proposées au sonder
celle qui arrive en tête cette année et
prendre du temps pour soi c'est le
souhait de 56 % des Français
deuxième position tiens ça va intéresser
manus 52% des Français veulent cette
année économiser de l'argent on compte
sur toi menu pour nous y aider inflation
oblige
2022 41% des Français avaient pour
bonnes résolution d'oser dire non venait
ensuite faire davantage attention à mes
dépenses
38% et faire plus attention à mon
alimentation et perdre du poids 37 %
n'était pas loin mais avant tout c'est
dire non aux autres non je ne ferai pas
ça non je ne vais pas vous faire plaisir
pour vous faire plaisir non ensuite
mieux s'organiser dans son quotidien
diminuer le gaspillage alimentaire mieux
manger se mettre ou se remettre au sport
à Pauline on va se mettre tout court
voilà ou bien être moins connecté à son
téléphone
une petite résolution pour l'année 2023
me mettre au sport un petit peu d'accord
c'est bien comme à peu près
99% des Français au moment où on se
parle c'est ça votre bonne résolution de
2023 c'est d'arrêter de faire des
réflexions de boomer aux enfants de vos
copains d'arrêter de corriger leur
syntaxe non mais tu sais c'est qui moi
c'est une phrase qui me rend dingue
[Musique]
je te répondrai ça va ça va ça va comme
si comme ça
le deuxième pays le plus inquiet en
matière climatique c'est la France on
est le deuxième le plus inquiet 74 %.
alors que si vous regardez il y a des
pays comme l'Arabie Saoudite alors ce
sont les moins inquiets ou même les
Chinois donc c'est inquiétant d'ailleurs
parce que là à beaucoup de pétrole
l'autre a beaucoup de population ce sont
les moins inquiets les Français ne
croient plus en la France et s'il
fallait s'en convaincre personne
n'imagine que les enfants nés au 21e
siècle vivront mieux que leurs parents
les Français ne croient plus en la
France c'est peut-être ça le plus
terrible comme si une certaine idée de
ce que nous sommes de ce que nous fumes
avait disparu bonne année quand même